sanctions imposed on Niger by West
African Regional block Echoes May cost
Nigeria 1.3 billion dollars every year
some analysts say the losses could be
more than economic the military coup now
in its third week threatens to change
relations between neighbors up and Idris
reports in the Border Town of magama
jibia
on the outskirts of the northern city of
Katina some 45 kilometers from the
border with Niger
trucks loaded with Goods wait to cross
the border
two weeks after the coup and with no
sign of a diplomatic breakthrough the
drivers fear a military escalation is
likely
the most difficult thing is uncertainty
around everything we don't know when
this Invasion will happen will it be
airaids or ground operation we hope we
won't get to that
many Nigerians say military action will
cause permanent damage to relations
between Nigeria and Niger the general
villain of the people in the state is
they are worried
they are worried they are worried they
are worried they don't want
they don't want us to go into war with
the Nigeria Republic
on the nature side of the Border here
too trucks trying to reach Nigeria are
located
these trucks have been in limbo since
the economic community of West African
States ordered all borders with Niger to
close for those transporting perishable
Goods especially fresh produce is a
total loss now the driver's main concern
is they don't know if and when they will
be able to live here
Echo sanctions have effectively cut off
supplies on both sides forcing families
to struggle
this is the most unsettling period for
everyone no one knows what to do anymore
as life is almost unbearable prices of
food items have doubled or even tripled
in some cases
many people in New Jersey Nigeria the
current chair of the West Africa
Regional block as leading the charge to
declare war on their country
opposition to military intervention in
Nigeria is more Fierce here in the north
than anywhere else in Nigeria
annalize a war between the two neighbors
made damage not only trade but also
familiar relations
ties That Bind the two countries for
centuries
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera magma jibia
well residents of the capital city in
the Army are calling for peace as
tensions continue to escalate many are
worried the standoff between coup
leaders and ecowas could result in more
violence some believe there should be a
peaceful transition of power that the
head of the Junta should beat the
nation's leader
what can ecowas do now are they going to
attack niger's presidential Palace to
save president Muhammad bazoom it makes
no sense I think the echoise heads of
state will be forced to come and
negotiate with the Junta in power in
Nigeria
and it should be in power for a while
but to negotiate him win short possible
time to give the power to a civilian
government
we support the cool 100 and we want
peace in our country whoever runs the
country we want peace that's our goal
is Deputy Africa director at Human
Rights Watch she says the coup leaders
are violating international human rights
law by detaining president bazoom
indeed we received reports that today he
was able to see his doctor but the
situation remains concerning we were
told uh by his family that they've not
had electricity as you mentioned since
August 2nd no contact with the outside
world since August 4th including with
his lawyer and the doctor who managed to
see him
um according to the reports uh today
family members and other friends who've
not you know have were not able to bring
the family food and other supplies we
were also told that without electricity
the family had now been reduced to
eating dry food
um and I think one of the most
concerning pieces of news was that
president bazoom's son has a serious
heart condition and needed to see a
doctor
um and the doctor alongside the family
lawyer at that time had not been able to
access a prison bazoom and and any of
the family members anyone we spoke to
including
own daughters and others including his
former communication advisor whether in
Nigeria or abroad informed Human Rights
Watch that they were concerned by the
length and arbitrary nature of the
president's detention because of the
toll that is obviously taking on the
president his family as well as other
senior government officials who have
been arbitrarily arrested and detained